[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime outport and the latest chapter
of the attack on Titan manga chapter 97
has recently become available and wow
what an insane mind-blowing chapter this
is I can't believe all the reveals that
we've gotten in this chapter including
the identity of the final the ninth and
final Titan shifter so yeah guys stay
tuned for this review it's gonna be
insane as always I'm not gonna do a lot
of visual editing for this video because
I want to get it out to you guys as soon
as possible but this has just been an
incredible chapter I am stunned
completely stunned by it if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe for
more videos like this if you enjoy these
reviews and our attack on Titan content
be sure to warhammer smash that like
button to let me know and let's just get
right into it
now first in the beginning of the
chapter we see a young blond girl with
glasses and a hat tailing Kenny Ackerman
in an attempt to get intel on the king
inside the walls
however Kenny is too smart to be
followed without noticing it and he
confronts the girl the girl begins
claiming that she is Kenny secret
daughter and when he becomes distracted
for an instant she uses the opportunity
to strike him and escape into the sewers
we soon realized that the girl in
disguise is Andy who was trying to track
down information about the true king
inside the walls we are looking at a
flashback to the 104th training core and
we see a private chat between Annie
Reiner and Bertolt where Annie briefs
them about her encounter with Kenny and
she fears that he has seen her face and
he suggests taking the Intel that they
have and just going back to Marlay
however Reiner says that if they do that
Marla will be disappointed and that what
they need to do is destroy wall rows
instead in order to push their way
closer to the royal capital and to the
king this all leads to yet more
information being revealed about Ryder's
inner conflict his desire to be a
faithful warrior of Marlay keeps
conflicting with his friendship with
Marco and the other recruits in the
104th Training Corps we learned that in
the present time he even seriously
contemplates suicide because of the
horrible situation that he finds himself
in but his desire to help falco and the
other young warriors and training stops
him from doing it an interesting thing
that comes out of the flashback
conversation between the three warriors
inside the walls is Berthold saying that
he keeps having the same dream about the
man who hung himself in the previous
chapter in the dream the man says why
did I tell you kids that just before I
hung myself and Ryan a responds with a
sharp look in my review of the previous
chapter I hypothesized that the Warriors
killed a man and made it look like
suicide so that they could take his
backstory and use it to infiltrate the
walls but it looks like if this really
was murder and not suicide Berthold was
not in on it
riders look tells me that maybe Reiner
killed the man on his own and made it
look like suicide because it was rather
convenient that the man would tell them
his backstory that he was the only
survivor from his village and then he
kills himself and gives the warriors the
perfect backstory that no one else could
disprove because no one from that
village is still alive however we will
have to wait and see if we get more info
on this specific incident in the coming
chapters back in the present we see that
Falco is troubled by the fact that he
isn't good enough to inherit the armored
Titan even though he wants to inherit it
so that he can save Gabby from having to
become a shifter Falco is then shown
talking to the mysterious wounded
soldier who was introduced a few
chapters ago the soldier says that he is
faking having PTSD and amnesia because
he can't face his family and then he
talks to talk about the warrior program
and Falco's desire to save Gabby at this
point we see this soldier having the
same conflicted emotions as rinder and
he is even questioning his own identity
and why is this the case because this
soldier is in fact revealed to be Eden
just look at that I Aaron has
infiltrated Marlay and what he found
there was that in Marla
not everyone is a monster either there
are kind people they're like falco on
the enemy's side and Reiner had
discovered the same thing about the LD
ins inside the walls and if this reveal
of air at having infiltrated marlane was
not enough we get an even bigger reveal
right in the next scene we learned the
identity of the ninth and final titan
shifter his name is Billy Tiber the head
of the Tiber family Billy meets
commander magatha
in Liberty oh and our first clue that
something is strange is that the Tiber
family seems to have taken over the
military headquarters and not only that
but they took it over not with Marlon
soldiers but using their own Royal Guard
so we learned that the Tiber family has
their own army inside Marlay Billy Tiber
reveals that even though very few people
know this even in the upper Merlin
hierarchy he is the possessor of the
Warhammer Titan power what's more we
learned that the nation of Marley is
secretly under the control of the Tiber
family just take a moment for that to
sink in the Tiber 'he's an LD and royal
family is secretly running marl a behind
the scenes Billy reveals that through
the memories of the Warhammer Titan he
has observed for over a century how the
Marlins have locked up and mistreated
the audience which has led both aldia
and Marley to fall into a deep darkness
at this point Billy says that they
intend to reveal everything at the
upcoming festival and he adds that at
this time Marley needs heroes we then
randomly see a frame of Zeke talking on
the phone and after that the final scene
takes us back to Falco the mysterious
veteran who calls himself mr. krüger a
reference to the owl
Ehren Kruger of course asks Falco to
deliver one of his letters to the
postbox
but he specifically tells him to deliver
it outside of the internment zone
because he doesn't want the Marlins to
check its contents and of course this
must be because he is secretly reporting
to Levi Mikasa and the others what he
has learned about Marley wow just wow
what an absolutely mind-blowing
incredible
chapter this leaves us with so many
questions why does the Tiber family
which controls Marlay from behind the
scenes allow the mistreatment of their
own fellow ldiots what is the type of
families true motive what is their end
goal
what will they reveal at the upcoming
festival what are Aaron and the others
planning will they make their move at
the festival as well this is gearing up
to be an absolutely amazing showdown
demonstrating yet again what a
phenomenal manga otago tine is this
chapter the anticipation the build-up in
this chapter was so good that I'm almost
afraid I'm honestly afraid guys that
attack on Titan the manga is gearing up
towards an end I know a lot of rumors
have said that attack attend manga will
be ending soon I understand that this is
not a long-running you know one piece
type shown in manga what I love this
manga I wanted to keep going at least
for a little while longer
and this set up is really to me saying
that this might be coming to a epic
conclusion but a conclusion nevertheless
sometime soon so let me know what you
think about that I'm definitely afraid
that it's gonna be coming to a
conclusion sometime soon with this much
being revealed in one chapter with so
much being set up the Tiber family is
gearing up to a big reveal at the
upcoming festival and then together with
the Warriors of Marlay they are planning
to attack Paradise Island and end the
war once and for all on the other hand
Aaron has infiltrated Marlay he is
monitoring the situation getting
acquainted with Marley and he's clearly
reporting back to Levi Mikasa Armin and
the rest of our crew back on paradise or
maybe they're already ill Marley
awaiting instructions maybe they are
going to strike first right there in
Marley maybe they're gonna use the
festival as a way to catch them our
lands by surprise we don't know but it's
gearing up to be an epic showdown
between the two factions another thing
that I thought was really interesting is
how they show just one frame of Zeke
just sort of talking on the phone I've
been safe for a while now and I
specifically made the argument in our
Kent Titans see the future video be sure
to check it out it's a theory video on
attack on Titan I've been saying that
Zeke is up to something
he's out
something that Marlay is not aware of I
don't think he's a black and white male
and warrior I think he is up to
something of his own creation remember
he said that he is somehow going to save
ed and he said that back earlier when he
was on parodies and now he is plotting
something I'm sure of it so let me know
what you think Zeke is up to why did he
appear in just this one single frame in
this manga is it telling us to expect
more from him to expect something crazy
from him let me know what you think in
the comments give me your thoughts down
below what did you think of this chapter
what did you think of the crazy reveals
I'm a little bit speechless myself let
me know your thoughts if you like these
reviews and want to see more attack on
titan content on this channel be sure to
leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to the channel don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell as always thank you so much for
watching be sure to leave your thoughts
in the comments and until next time see
ya space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you